ما مدى صحة هذا الزلزال الكبير ،
فنحن ننتظر أنه لا يزال مستمراً ،
انظر إلى الأضواء بسرعة ،
آسف ، لا يزال الأمر جيدًا
يهز الكاميرا تهتز ، لقد
التقطتها للتو تعيش على الهواء مباشرة وتلمع
زلزال الجميع في المترو
عادة ما نفعله  عدم الحصول على التحديث
من USGS لمدة 10 دقائق تقريبًا أو نحو ذلك ، لذا
سنراقب ذلك عن كثب
وأتوقع أننا سنحصل
على تحديث آخر لأن هناك
على الأقل بعد الهزات ما لم يكن هذا
وعظًا  من ER doc ، نعم ، ليسوا يعملون ،
نعم الزلازل ولكن رائعًا ، لقد
فعلتها Amy ، نعم في مكان ما على الهواء ، لا
أعرف ما حدث ، كان الأشخاص الذين يقفون خلف
الكاميرات كالنوم أو شيء
مشابه لك ، أنت متأكد من أنك لا
تتوقع  لقد أصبت بالذهول ، لكني في
البداية كنت متحمسًا للغاية بشأن
الزلازل ، كنت على ما يرام أولاً
، أعتقد أن مكيف الهواء
، والآن هو بالتأكيد
زلزال ، أنا متأكد من أنكم شعرتم به جيدًا يا رفاق